Hello, everyone, so my name is Brenna, I'm
from Toronto in Canada and I'm a front-end engineer
at tent. But before that I actually taught
at a Front‑End development boot camp for
a year. I want to tell you a little story
about something that happened there that came
to be known as the "oprah circle" so the very
first time we ran this boot camp everything
was sort of experiment, we were feeling it
out as we went along and we kind of followed
the normal course you would started out with
a couple weeks over HTML and CSS followed
by a few weeks of JavaScript and then something
happened in the weeks immediately following
JavaScript, there was a weird tension hanging
over the entire classroom. We got this feeling
that we had like defeated people. And so we
decided that we needed to do something, we
staged an intervention of sorts. We gathered
all of our 27 or so students in a circle,
and we asked them all to share a highlight
of the course so far, followed by a low light
and then another highlight. So the low lights
ranged from things you would expect like:
I don't get to see my friends and family as
much, I have a long commute. Halve of my students
gave me a one word answer "javaScript" JavaScript
was a low light for them, this broke my heart
the JavaScript community is personally where
I have felt like the most inspired, the most
supported, the most welcome in my own journey
as a Front‑End developers and I wanted to
know why aren't these people new to the is
industry feeling the love, why haven't they
seen the good parts of the community. If you
think about it, this isn't that surprising,
learning to code is a hard challenging thing
to do, there are barriers involved. Today
I want to talk about those barriers, some
of them are technical, some of them are cultural,
and I want to talk about the solutions to
help overcome them for the newest members
of our community. One thing that I think is
really critical to remember is that many newcomers
to JavaScript are new to the world of programming
in a lot of ways. This happens really frequently
and increasingly because the demand for JavaScript
developers is so high and we have a hugh influx
of people that are coming in from non‑traditional
backgrounds and looking maybe formal computer
science training. I think many of us sort
of build up our JavaScript knowledge like
this. We're able to get the job done and like
ship something out, but in essence we're looking
a solid foundation beneath that. One great
strategy for dealing with this is just to
read a book that covers these fundamental
topics, there are a ton of them available
on‑line for free. So whether this be for
yourself our to recommend to somebody who's
kind of struggling building those foundations
this is a good resource, eloquent JavaScript
in particular, a lot of people said they've
had good success with that. And when you're
looking these foundations it fundamentally
comes down to communication problem. How often
do we tell people oh, you have a problem in
your code? Just Google it. And while it's
true that most of the answers are out there
somewhere in the internet, how can somebody
formulate an intelligent question and find
their way there if they don't use the correct
terminology, if they don't speak the language.
So, this I found was happening with a lot
of my students, we just weren't seeing eye
to eye as far as talking about the concepts
that we were trying to debug, I used a little
technique I call hooked on syntax. So, something
like this, pretty simple line of code. Maybe
if you are, you know, reasonably profish innocent
JavaScript, you can read that and sort of
parse out what it does immediately in your
head. But for a beginner, you have to interpret
all this. That's a lot that you're doing implicitly.
I literally would sit with students and say
let's sound this out word by word. Var, what
is that, that's a key word that exists in
JavaScript and it says hey, I'm going to go
create a variable. Max number, what is that?
And you know, I know that that's something
that I made up, I got to name that, but that's
not something that's always clear to a beginner,
so you really have to be patient with people
as they're going through things like this.
And this is actually like a tough thing for
me to do as a teacher, like I struggle to
be patient. It's so tempting when the someone
has a problem, hear's the answer I'll give
it to you, but they're never going to learn
like that. One thing that infuriates me the
most when I see a more experience developer
(infuriates) come over to someone's computer
and literally take over and type on it. You
need to let that person, as painstaking as
it might be, type things out really slowly
for themselves and actually learn and internalize
and make their own mistakes. And returning
to this idea of keeping track of a lot of
language and syntax and terminology, we really
need to remember that this is not a test.
We're brought up with this culture of memorization,
all throughout like most of our traditional
schooling, we learn something and then we're
tested on it and usually we just have to memorize
the thing that we're being tested on this
is not in any way like a typical programmers
work flow. Personally, I have the syntax for
something like a four memorized because I've
written it thousands of times, but I never
Satoshi there with flash cards and memorized
for a 404 loop is, for some reason people
that are entering don't get that, they feel
a pressure that they have to memorize it.
I want you to tell people it's okay to look
it up. There's no shame in looking something
up that you don't know (Memorize it) let's
provide them with resources to do this. This
is just like a quick cheat sheet I through
together for some of my students. I could
tell that they were just overwhelmed with
all of this and it really helped to have that
security blanket there, so share these resources
with people or create them yourself. Another
challenge for a lot of beginners is specially,
especially for people coming in from HTML
and CSS, that has a lot of immediate feedback
and visual output. So JavaScript can be really
dry and abstract and boring. One thing, I
think we need to to do is stop using Foo and
bar, extremely achieving tract things in our
example, use something with context that actually
means something to someone. You know, if I
see black and Orange, I understand that those
are both colors and they're related and helps
me grasp the con sect that an array is a collection
of related items. The thing with this too
is it's also memorable. So, who recognizes
this? It's a closing brace. Closing parenthesis
and a semi colon. It's a familiar pattern
that we see at the end of a lot of call back
functions and if you're experienced you recognize
this. To a beginner you miss one piece of
punctuation and everything stops. And you
see syntax error on‑line 24, and which one
of these is missing. Who knows. How do you
get someone to build the memory for that signature,
recognize this and know that this is the correct
way to to it. You give it a silly nickname.
If you ask any one of the hundred or so people
that taught JavaScript to last year, they
will all immediately tell you this is the
frownny winky neck beard. (Laughing) (Frownywinkyneckbeard)
similarly, dollar signs parens came to be
know Q query activate! Because when you have
something and you want to be able to use J
query methods on it, you need to activate
the J query by swadelling it in dollar signs
and parens. The moral is to have fun with
it. I think you're an incredibly fun bunch
of people when I meet you in person, why not
bring that liveliness in our on‑line examples
and make ourselves more memorable to beginners
(Liveliness) so, time for another problem.
If you've got your fundamentals down you know
the mechanics of how things work. A ton of
people really struggle with tackling a larger
problem. They say where do I start? It's sort
of libelerring to use a saw and a hammer and
a tape measure individually. And then all
of a sudden someone says build me a bookcase.
Where do I start with that? And I think this
is actually where a lot of online tutorials
miss the mark they teach you the mechanics,
they don't teach you the art of problem solving.
That's a skill, once you're an experienced
developer you gain. So, I think we need to
teach people to think like a computer. Try
and get them to break town a complex problem
into dis‑‑ break down a complex problem
into discreet steps you want to get them writing
pseudo code. You're giving them little baby
portions to chew off one piece at a time that
they can match up with their Toolkit a little
easier. And I think we can do stuff in our
community to facilitate that and give people
an environment where they can take on those
bigger problems and have support through working
through the stages. This is a picture from
note school Toronto T school is a‑‑
note school is a fantastic organization in
tons over cities easy to start a chapter if
there isn't one where you live. Anyone is
welcome to come and work through a tutorial
or hack on their own projects and it's completely
casual and informal but there's support there.
There's experienced developers, there's peers
to help them through that and sort of learn,
you know, that more difficult art of actually
working through real world problems that you're
solving with JavaScript. What this comes down
to in essence even though a lot of these are
more technical strategies, is this is about
being welcoming to newcomers, just really
taking them under your wing and helping them
get oriented in what is kind of a strange
new world if you've never seen JavaScript
before. So, let's assume our foundation is
built, we know how to use all our tools and
when to use them. You're eventually going
to come up against this. it's so great that
a lot of us have passion about JavaScript
and how to write it, but with all these strong
opinions flying around this is what it feels
like. People get totally concerned about what's
the right way to do it? I've seen it so bad
20 the point (People get totally) people are
scared to write town any code because they're
afraid to do it the wrong way. Now part of
this is JavaScript itself. Our lovely little
language has so many instances where there
are literally multiple ways to accomplish
the same task. This happens on a macro scale
as well. I think it's incredibly healthy that
we have a rich ecosystem of frameworks and
tooling this can get extremely overwhelming
when you're faced with all the choices and
you're not sure which one you should be using.
Beyond this it's really not helpful when we're
constanthly critiquing penal for using last
year's model. We need to let go the idea of
there being one true way to do something.
Encourage beginners to pick a method, pick
a framework and give it a try. If you don't
like it or if it doesn't work for you, then
try something new. You know. If it gets the
job done, in my opinion, that's the right
choice. Let people learn for themselves what
the maybe the pitfalls of using something
is on their own let them learn their lessons,
we think we have done a good job with this
paradox of choice is through things like code
style guides and best practices, people are
really looking for guidance here. I heard
this answer over and over and over again that
I just don't know which thing to do. So, give
them guidance. These are great tools to use
either if you're learning on your own, someone
comes at you with an opinion, no, I did it
with this way because the AirBnB Java guide
said so, shut that down. Also if you're leading
a team where you're managing a bunch of junior
developers, implement something like this
so you can stop people arguing on your team
and get people to writing JavaScript together
as a team. If you're outside of these formal
places where it's allowed to set the one true
way, we all need to bite our damn tongues.
This probably happened to a lot of other people
in audience, you post a piece of code on‑line,
all of a sudden, you have like opinions flying
at you about oh, you should do it this way
instead, have be you considered that in imstead,
why not say something like can I give you
a suggestion instead of just flying at someone
with the way that you think it's supposed
to be done. If you start a conversation like
this, you're going to just like open up a
dialogue where you can talk constructively
about maybe the benefits and draw backs of
different options without it being so hostile.
And when you are giving help to someone, b
writing a Blog post, GitHub issues stockover
flow answer, I think we need to chose our
words really wisely. There's a great Blog
post by Chris Coyier about words to avoid
in Eckcational writing. Educational writing
is anything Blog post stackover flow. If you
use words like obviously, just, simply, you're
implying that the task is easy. But the audience
are beginners, it's nota city for them, by
using these words you've completely trivialize
their struggle. And if you take the words
out of the sentence, it reads exactly the
same way any way. Just don't do it. What this
is empathy really. You need to try and remember
what it was like when you were learning, and
there's psychology there that the further
you get from your beginner stage the more
expert you become it's actually just harder
to remember what it was like when you were
a beginner, but I urge you all to just try
before you answer someone who's in a more
junior position, take a second and try to
see their perspective of where they're coming
from. This also applies with documentation.
As a rather famous quote from Kathy Sierra,
if you want them to RTFM, make a better FM.
I literally do not think I've ever heard someone
complain about documentation being too easy
to understand so why not just make it accessible
to everybody. I know it's not everybody's
favorite task, but it is so, so critical there's
resources to help you write the docks that
can help you with this. All of this is the
idea of being supportive instead of just critiquing.
We quantity to be offering up resources and
encouragement. And so I also think we knead
to just like to out of our way to be encouraging
to other people. (Laughing) (Need) want to
take that in a couple more times. You know,
I think in general humans are faster to offer
up' negative opinion than a positive one.
We tend to hold that back. So just be encouraging
whether that's in the form of like a high
five when someone's debugging something and
they get it to work, celebrate the is small
wins, tell somebody if you think they did
something great. I'm sure they would love
to hear it. And sometimes that also means
just giving somebody a gentle nudge. Pushing
them outside of their comfort zone. There
are so many people that have done this to
me when I thought, no, I can't talk at a conference,
I don't have anything to say, I don't have
anything anyone wants to hear, I think Brian
summed this up really well this morning. But,
yeah, try and push people out of their comfort
zone and encourage them to take leaps. Okay,
so, one more big thing I think I need to address.
A lot of people feel like this. As they continue
in their journey they've learned a lot of
foundations, they've maybe like been able
to deal with the negative opinions coming
in, but the more you see the industry, I think
for a lot of people they start to feel leek
they don't quite fit in here. So, sometimes
it's literally I don't look like you. I don't
look like a developer, but even regardless
of that, I think all of us have been fed this
false narrative that in order to be successful
as a developer, as a JavaScripter. You need
to devote your entire life to code. You're
not allowed to have outside hobbies, you'll
never get ahead if you're not coding every
single night. I think this is entirely false.
One of my students went through the boot camp,
I became friends with her, she got a job with
a well known agency. On the books she was
successful as a web developer. Personally
she confided in me she was thinking of quitting.
She said I'd like to make something with my
hands, I want to maybe just go into woodworking
and do that instead. Instead. To her it was
a binary option. She couldn't be a JavaScript
developer and do something like this on the
side. And I said, no, no, no, wait it's okay.
I know developers who are carpenters. Anyone
know will more key, he still does it ton side,
he's done great talks about how that influences
his JavaScript work. There are developers
who are in to perfectly clear ice. (Laughing)
and how do I know this? I know this because
they freely volunteer that information on
Twitter publically (Laughing) but I think
that's great. I think‑‑ we should all
just not be shy about who we rein our lives
outside of JavaScript and share your lovely
unique selves, because I fundamentally believe
teach and every one of you is totally awesome.
Yeah. Clap for yourselves. (Applause) by having
unique interests, and knowledge from outside
JavaScript or computer science we all bring
something incredibly unique to the table.
And I think we're better off as an industry
for it. Diverse people are going to look at
things in different ways and solve diverse
problems. And where I think the magic really
happens is when we take our interests and
hobbies and combine them with JavaScript to
make truly inspiring things that appeal to
a much wider audience. General for example
loves art, loves pixel art, so she does that
on‑line, she makes a lot of art with JavaScript.
I'm also incredibly inspired by our determination
to use JavaScript outside the browser. Node
happened not to long ago we decided hey, we're
stuck with JavaScript, I think it's sort of
started where all of us were stuck with JavaScript
because it's the only thing that runs in the
browser and then this school thing happened
where we're like we're just going to put it
elsewhere and run with it. So we got node
with JavaScript on the server. And then we
got Nodebots with JavaScript running on our
Arduino boards and people like Sandra mesh
always been into suing since a kid now she
makes wearables that are controlled by JavaScript.
And this idea of JavaScript all the things
just keeps growing and growing. I never imagined
that I'd see JavaScript on a nitting machine,
but Mariko did this. Hopefully you all saw
her talk reject JS. All of these people I
just showed you and so, so many others that
I don't have time to mention have inspired
me to stick with JavaScript rather than any
other language. They've inspired me to continue
learning when I felt like I knew nothing to
work on interesting side projects in my spare
time when I didn't have the motivation. That's
why I'm standing here talking to you today.
Me, and I think so many other people in this
room just really finally felt I have a place
where I belong. So to me, those are the good
parts. We're welcoming in terms of helping
people build a solid foundation and building
communities. We're supportive when we reserve
judgement and offerer encouragement instead.
And we're inspiring by just being cool awesome
people and making really interesting things
with JavaScript all over. But not everybody
knows this yet. Not everyone has had a chance
to come to a conference like this and see
the good parts. So my call, to all of you,
is to take whatever you see as the good parts
of this community and share it beyond these
walls. Thank you. (Applause).